the war of words between President Trump
and freshman congresswoman ilhan Omar is
also heating up Mr Trump is now
defending his supporters who chanted
send her back at a rally earlier this
week and Omar is calling herself the
president's quote nightmare the
president is spending the weekend in New
Jersey Ben Tracy is traveling with him
Ben good morning
Jeff good morning we don't yet know if
the president's going to Brave the Heat
and go golfing today but we do know that
he is already up and on Twitter
president once again defending himself
saying that he did nothing to lead on
these chants at his rally earlier this
week and calling the crowd patriotic the
president has made an Abrupt change no
longer disavowing his supporters but
defending them
as you know those are incredible people
those are incredible Patriots in the
Oval Office Friday president Trump took
the side of those who chanted send her
back at a rally in North Carolina
Wednesday
[Applause]
this was widely seen as a racist attack
on Minnesota congresswoman ilhan Omar
originally from Somalia but now an
American citizen after the first lady
the president's daughter Ivanka and
several Republican lawmakers expressed
their concerns about the ugly scene the
president offered a tepid rebuke I
disagree with it by the way but it was
quite a chant and I felt a little bit
badly about it but less than 24 hours
later Mr Trump was back to blaming Omar
you know what I'm unhappy with I'm
unhappy with the fact that a
congresswoman can hate our country I'm
unhappy with the fact that a
congresswoman can say anti-semitic
things the president seems to see
political advantage in his Feud with the
four Democratic congresswomen known as
the squad especially Omar who has been
particularly outspoken
when she returned to Minnesota Thursday
Omar was defiant saying as an immigrant
in Congress she is the president's
nightmare we are going to continue to be
a nightmare to this president
because his policies are a nightmare to
us
not frightened we are ready that got
under the president's skin I'm unhappy
what a congresswoman goes and said I'm
going to be the president's nightmare
she's going to be the president's
nightmare
she's lucky to be where she is let me
tell you
the president keeps saying that it's not
okay for these congresswomen to
criticize the country or his policies
but when the president was asked why it
was okay for him to call the United
States a laughing stock or its foreign
policy stupid before he was elected
president he didn't really answer it he
just said this is the best country in
the world Elaine all right Ben Tracy
thank you